♫ In my dreams
♫ I see your face
♫ Walk with you
♫ Hold you safe
- [Father] My son Lee,
he went missing in 1988,
on September the 10th.
- [Father] My daughter
Claudia went missing eight
and a half years ago, when she was 35.
- My brother's a missing person.
He's been missing for 22 years.
And that's why I joined the choir to meet
other families and have
support from the choir.
- The Missing People Choir is made up
of family's with missing loved ones
and volunteers that want to sing with us.
- I sing my heart out for my boy.
I can't talk to him,
but I sing, I sing to him all the time
when I'm with the choir.
- Connecting with other people
who've had a missing loved
one is really special.
And for me, it was 19
years before I met anybody
who was in the same situation.
You know, we know what each of us has gone through
and we just connect with each other
in a very particular way.
(laughing)
- [James] Britain's Got
Talent was an incredible,
a juggernaut of an experience.
♫ Touch you
- That's incredible.
(cheering and applause)
- [James] Our win wasn't going
to be the big prize money
or a big single or anything like that,
it was actually, find someone.
That's what we went out to achieve.
- One young man even came back
because he saw his face on the appeals,
and he'd been missing for six weeks.
He was only a young boy
and he reconnected with his mother
after listening to us singing on BGT.
- Where words end, music carries on.
And so when you apply it to
causes that really matter
and that resonate with people,
you know, it's extremely powerful stuff.
And it's beautiful.
- Daughter.
- Son.
- Brother.
♫ I miss you